right-hander luis castillo
seeking his first win of 2020 as you
look at his home and road splits well
you know i'm not sure if there's a big
enough sample size to start splitting up
this way but it does show you that he's
pitched better than his record shows ian
happ is going to lead things off for the
chicago cubs swing and a miss
good start for luis
good change up right over the inside
corner rizzo at first and the batter is
kyle schwarber swinging in a miss he
struck him out count on strikes kyle
schwarber castillo fans two in the first
well to me first and foremost for chatty
you know this is his second start coming
off the dl the first one was was not
very good he just didn't have command
today it's all about his command of his
fastball two outs here's jesse winker
swinging a bouncing ball slowly hit
right side fueled by baez he'll flip the
first and it's a one two three first
stunning for tyler chatwood cubs get a
man on and it brings up jason kipnis
with one away in a scoreless game in the
second inning could be two although
garcia and the shift has to run and make
a tag and got him heads-up play by the
rookie off the bat you're thinking okay
classic double play ball but there was
no one at second base
so now a base hit could drive in a pair
and the pitch to nico horner tapper back
to the mound castillo gloves sets his
feet throws in time to get the out on
horner at first
and the inning is over with one away
akiyama with good speed at first pitch
stavato in the dirk bounces right up and
hits contreras i think something
happened on this pitch to
chatwood he's instantly calling the
trainers out he throws this pitch back
and i mean it literally
hits right at the edge of the grass in
the dirt i mean it's five feet six feet
in front of home plate it's a shame
chetwood will leave the game he's
pitching very well today luis castillo
to start off this at-bat to schwarber
struck out his first time up swinging a
drive right center field and deep it's
got a
chance gone
get out the tape measure for kyle
schwarber a long home run hubs laid one
to nothing fourth home run for kyle
off of castile
and and that is pretty amazing and only
19 at bats but i believe this is a
change up that ends up down and in the
middle of the plate and it's a middle
you know it's a change up 87 mile an
hour change up and kyle hit it about 430
feet from home plate here's jason
hayward stepping up and hayward gets a
hold of one and it will
go
two to nothing
hayward just reaches out
and he hooks this change up and both
home runs in this inning won by
schwarber one by hayward both off change
ups one away two nothing cubs a eu genio
suarez the batter here's the swing of
the drive right center field on the run
is half making a diving catch
the bull started to knuckle on him as it
moved toward right center half ended up
diving and grabbing it for out number
two rudder on at first base nobody out
and now castillo goes to work against
ian happ hit in the air to deep center
field going back akayama he leaps and
this one is gone a home run
for ian happ cubs extend the lead four
to nothing now over the reds
on the two-run shot by ian happ his
eighth a happer gets a 0-2 slider
third and he just stays on this ball
hamburger now jason hayward's the hitter
here's the pitch to jason swinging a
drive deep right field it's got a chance
in the corner gone another home run for
jason hayward
his second of the day a line smash right
down the right field line
his fifth of the season and the cubs
lead by a high five joey votto leads off
the sixth inning against jose quintana
fly ball pretty well hit center field
going back on in half he's at the
warning track at the wall it's gone
bottle got it out of here just to the
right of dead central and he has the
reds on the board with his fifth home
run of the year well they got around
that fastball no doubt about it lefty on
lefty botto the ball is up there he just
provided the bat head
rubs have belted four home runs today
the guy at the plate has one ian half
her ball drilled in the air right field
deep back toward the wallace castigano's
home run
in half with a line drive home run to
right
but cubs have belted their fifth round
tripper of the day
second for ian happ cubs lead six to one
aces full of reds two strikes two outs
trying to climb back in it
here in the seventh castillanos lines
one and a diving catch by nico horner at
second base and that ends the inning
what a play as the bags are loaded with
two down for kyle schwarber drilled in
the air deep right field of its home run
i mean if it's fair it's going to be
gone it's long gone it's a grand slam
for kyle schwarber
and the cubs lead by a score of ten to
one
a line drive slammed to the seats in
right
and the cubs have broken it wide open
his second of the day
schwarber's ninth of the season a rocket
to the seats in right
and just like that the reds are down to
their last chance breaking ball strike
three called cubs win the ball game
underwood strikes out the side the cubs
hammer the reds by a score of ten to one